you want to go first no right now I'm
mad at him that's true
it's absolutely true this is no set if
she's ticked at me and she deserves to
be but I'm also happy that people
watched and smiled like my goal is to
make people smile all show and to be a
better dancer as the show climbs I want
to get better as the show goes but I
want people to think at any time I can
do anything that's gonna make them smile
because they don't know what's gonna
happen that literally is my goal and she
didn't know I was gonna do that tonight
apparently now it is apparently now it
is I don't want to I don't want to
control I just want him to believe in
the dancing that he does I love the way
he celebrates and I love what he brings
to the dancefloor I just want him to
finish the last move that's all and then
he can celebrate him body I didn't
finish the last move last week either I
know I get a little too excited but I
feel like America will be excited like I
feel like I'm representing the people
out there and I'm not cool and so yeah
it is what it is I'm not super proud of
it but I'm kind of proud of it I have
the best partner she's gonna make me
better and by week four five six seven
we're gonna be dancing our brains down
they're gonna go wow look how this guys
went from a goofball to an actual dancer
that's the growth that I want to show
I'm not even in a car but I'm gonna
press the light on the track and love
him just do you think that's it that's
what's happening for the Freestyle I'll
press play he can take care of the rest
of it better dancing better form and a
magic trick oh there's a magic trick
that we're gonna crush Charlotte I'm her
assistant in the magic trick she
dominates the magic trick and we cut
someone in half so I'm really excited
about the and I have to go last I hadn't
had to go last tonight I hated that I
wanted to last you got a shoot cannon
out your butt to go laughs and that's
what we did I don't wanna go last ever
again never I won't ever go to last ever
again
I feel like I'm ahead right it's not
about behaving at all I want him to
believe in the work that he did through
the week to execute the dance to its
fullest and then let loose and do him
really hard the hours that we that we
needed to do this we couldn't get
because it just wasn't enough of them to
dances this week was an impossible task
for a lot of couples on this show and
yet we got out there and we did an
incredible job and tomorrow is amazing
also so I'm proud of everybody on this
cast and this guy right here
I think it's probably when she slapped
me but afterward that spray tan went
onto my jacket
I think you've that flower there's no
chain on the flower listen I would like
to say America I'm sorry and I love you
both
[Music]
[Applause]